welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
this is your one and only full-time
permanent host of the show eric trexler
but today i am joined by a special
temporary guest co-host his name is greg
knuckles greg thanks for joining me
thanks for having me on how you doing
today
doing well how are you i am doing great
uh we've got a lot of good content
planned for this episode but before we
get into that
uh another reminder here we are let's
see this episode's going up on thursday
which is thanksgiving day
so if uh if you're in the united states
celebrating thanksgiving uh hope you
enjoy it
uh that also means it's right in the
middle of our big black friday sale for
mass
so mass is our monthly research review
it stands for monthly applications and
strength sport
our big sale goes from november 22nd to
november 29th we do it every year around
black friday time
and uh yeah it's our biggest best sale
of the year it's a really good one so
mass if you're not familiar is uh our
research review with 10 pieces of
content per month it's written by me
greg dr eric helms and dr mike zordos
and as i mentioned in our last episode
there's a pretty big announcement for
the upcoming issue
uh we are expanding the segment that we
call research briefs or the uh
section of mass so research briefs is
really cool you started it you pioneered
the idea
it's shorter summaries of many studies
and so what's exciting is that starting
december 1st and every issue after
the research briefs
section is expanded which effectively
doubles the number of studies that we
cover every month when you compare to
like the first issue ever you look like
you had something to say i was just
going to say if if people know anything
about me you should you should know that
i'm always a pioneer in the general
field of brevity yes that that has
always been my
been my specialty
that's one of our biggest challenges
just expanding it into a new medium yeah
as as the director producer and chief
content creator for this podcast one of
my biggest challenges is trying to get
some more words out of you get a little
bit more engagement
um but yeah so so uh research briefs is
expanding which means we're really
substantially increasing the study
coverage every month but you know when
it comes to mass it's not just about
summarizing studies it's always written
with the purpose of emphasizing
practical applications so if you're
really into fitness for your own
purposes or if you are a coach or a
trainer who works with clients what we
try to do with mass is
take the newest research available that
is directly applicable to what you're
doing break down the research describe
what it means and really focus on how
you would apply it to your training or
the training and nutrition habits of
your clients
so during the black friday sale it's our
lowest prices of the year uh if you sign
up during that sale you get locked in at
your subscription price so you can
really take advantage of that lower
monthly rate uh we do have discounts for
our monthly subscriptions in addition to
our annual
and our lifetime subscription options
if you're not certain if you're ready to
subscribe you can check out a free issue
you can find that at
strongerbyscience.com slash mass best of
with hyphens between those words
and like i said the sale ends november
29th another perk uh i'm about to sneeze
but i might hold it in another perk is
if you sign up during the sale uh true
professional this yeah this is serious
on-air talent uh
if you say i don't know too well about
rush i never heard him sneeze on air
that is pretty wild uh i know the pros
have a sneeze button but that still if
you're on camera you can't just bail uh
yeah he must have just never sneezed
anyway
if you sign up during the sale another
perk is that uh there's a charity
component
so a hundred percent of your first
month's payment will go to charity uh if
you do a monthly subscription or if you
do an annual or a lifetime subscription
21
uh is going to be going to that charity
and the charity is uh
oriented kind of aimed at uh reducing
hunger and supporting food banks in the
united states another way to support the
show if you feel so inclined would be to
subscribe to our diet app called macro
factor and of course a third way is to
use the discount code sbs pod when
you're checking out at
bulksupplements.com
for a five percent discount on your
order
okay moving on road to the stage how is
it going greg
uh wrote the stage is uh
currently on pause
uh but that's a good thing it's been a
very productive pause
um i had a
can't really call it a short-term goal i
had a moderate term goal of getting
below 235 uh that's
what i weighed uh just before getting
married back in 2013
so
i am
now lighter than i have been in what i
would personally consider my adult life
which is nice um so yeah i wanted to get
there before the holidays glad i made it
and for the holidays i don't want to
face the expectation of continuing to
lose weight when there's
thanksgiving leftovers and and holiday
treats in the house holiday beers which
are very underrated beers yeah um oh man
what
what did i just get
it doesn't matter
whatever i i got some pretty good uh
christmas belgian ales that i'm blanking
on the name of anyway
um so yeah uh shifted back to
maintenance
and uh that's going that's going really
well um
this is the first time
in a while
uh first time that i can remember that
uh i've lost a pretty substantial amount
of weight
uh
you know ended my my active intentional
period of weight loss
and i didn't immediately just like gorge
myself and gain back 10 pounds
um
and i think one of the major reasons for
that is that i i have been taking things
slowly enough to develop better habits
this time around
so like by the numbers um
and i mean this relates to
pretty much everything we talk about
that as long as you're making progress
like good things add up over time um
but
up to this point i've been
cutting i i think slower than just about
anyone who would would recommend or
like below the bottom end of like
recommended rates of weight loss that
that people would give like
you know most of the time people say
like ah you're good to lose about
half a percent to one percent of your
body weight per week and if you go
slower than that um
you know that's fine but real really all
you're doing is just like prolonging
uh prolonging your cut
and you don't really get anything for it
um but in my case i think it's been
pretty clutch so i i've lost like 31
pounds over the last eight months
um
or close to nine months so it's it's
been at a rate of like about point three
percent of my body weight per week point
three point four
uh less than a pound per week starting
at a body weight of 266 which
is a pretty slow
rate of weight loss
um
but the benefit of that is the deficit
i've been in has been small enough
that i i've basically been able to
develop new habits such that
i've been close enough to maintenance
that i'm
um
like
developing a new way for myself to eat
that should be sustainable so
shifting back to maintenance this time
i didn't necessarily feel deprived or
super hungry
as this phase of my cut was finishing up
so i didn't like
feel the need to go out and eat a bunch
of stuff like currently my my approach
to maintenance has been to just keep
eating exactly like i was when i was
dieting but then just have another like
three 400 calories left over at the end
of the day for a snack or to drink a
beer or two um
so like fundamentally not much has
changed and that was
that was possible
because i never felt particularly
deprived on my diet um
so yeah uh
that that has all been good um so i'm
like mid
i'm i'm about halfway from where i
started to where i want to be
with this dot like longer term uh diet
uh and this this little uh mile post
makes me optimistic that that i'm gonna
be able to keep it off um
you know just because like my my
experience with maintenance
thus far
uh has been a lot better than than it
has been previously when i've lost a
fair bit of weight yeah i mean that's uh
it's such a shift in the way you
approach dieting but like
i think a lot of people when they begin
a diet they
immediately restrict as much as they can
feasibly do in the short term right they
maximize their restriction
and say okay this is the
lowest calorie intake that i can
tolerate in the short term
and then they
stick with that for as long as they can
manage it you know so the lowest
tolerable calories for the longest
tolerable amount of time and then
eventually
you get to a point where they're like
okay i'm gonna shift to maintenance but
they they have this long uh
process of being
overly restrictive for an extended
period of time and kind of reach what's
functionally like a breaking point and
that leads into what you were describing
where it's like okay shifting to
maintenance then becomes a pretty
turbulent process that often involves
overeating more than was planned and
some weight regained uh but taking a
slower approach even if it's not the
exact percentage that people often
recommend
like you said it's it's a much more
enjoyable process it's a smoother
process and you can get to these mile
posts these mile markers and say i'm
going to pause it here without any major
turbulence in that process yeah so it's
it's a really nice way to approach it
yeah i'm basically
i think ultimately i'm going to
accomplish in
a year and a half two years what i
could have done in six months if i was
quite a bit more aggressive but
ultimately i'm more concerned about like
where am i going to be in five years
yeah um
and yeah i think that this
i think that this approach will be more
sustainable
um and yeah i i
i mean like i just said i
though
i've been losing
uh like i said
somewhere in the neighborhood of like
point eight pounds per week or so yeah
um and i i can do that
i can do that without feeling deprived
like
i'm sure i'm sure as i lose more weight
i will get hungrier and hungrier
um
but i mean like overall like
eating basically like i would
if i were at maintenance but just kind
of
cutting out a beer cutting out a snack
here and there um like i think that
that's
helping me build the skills that i'll
need to sustain this where whereas like
if i would have just lost all of the
weight in six months i i don't know if
if i would have those skills right
good stuff man that's awesome tell me
about uh tell me about the road to
athens
the road to athens is treacherous it
really is uh so
i kind of committed to the outline
before i did my my big run this past
weekend
uh
so i wrote in saturday morning run 12
miles time and then i left it blank
i filled out the time and the time i put
in is yes
because
i did in fact cover 12 miles on saturday
they were 12 of the
ugliest most labored miles you've ever
seen it felt like i was running with
cinder blocks attached to my feet
but
it got done and i was actually really
stoked because i
i didn't just think about turning around
i literally turned around uh because the
way i was doing it was six miles out six
miles back
i was probably four and a half miles out
and i literally turned around
and only made it about 10 steps in the
wrong direction and then say said damn
it
you got to do this because it's in the
outline already so then i turned back
around and so if anybody was passing by
on the trail they're probably what the
hell's this guy doing
uh but no i went six miles and then i
went six miles back
uh at the six mile marker it it it kind
of sucks because the push up to that
turnaround point is
a fairly nasty uphill grade
uh so i really had to push it and uh i
stopped for a moment
at that turnaround point to make sure i
wasn't having like an asthma attack
uh or some kind of anaphylactic reaction
and it turns out nope just out of shape
so
i i for the first time in a while felt
like i could not oxygenate my body
um but uh took a few deep breaths and
was good to go so uh the road to athens
is going well and i'm pretty stoked
about it so i'll continue to provide
some updates and as we move forward i'll
talk a little bit more about my strategy
for how i want to continue to develop
these uh different
uh you know energy systems and endurance
and things like that but
my starting point so far has been to
emphasize variability
so like i said my my big hurdle usually
is lower extremity injury due to overuse
and a big contributor to that in my
opinion is just having
the same exact running stride step step
step step times hundreds of thousands
there's no variability in that movement
the tissues are being strained in the
exact same way every single repetition
or step
and i think when you're not accustomed
to that mileage yet if you're trying to
overdo the volume before you've built up
uh the tolerance for that at the tissue
level you can run into some issues one
of my big
one of my secret weapons when i first
get into running is trail running
trail running first of all is way more
enjoyable because there's trees and
stuff
i get very bored on a treadmill or just
on a flat road
trail running when you have to navigate
some root systems uh the downside of
course is your you might fall
and you open yourself up to ankle
injuries you open yourself up to foosh
injuries or falling on an outstretched
hand
but if you can avoid those instances
i find it very helpful as you're
navigating root systems in different
terrain when trail running each stride
is a little bit different there's a lot
more variability in the movement and so
you're not doing the same exact impact
over and over so both for enjoyment
purposes and for slightly you know
physiological purposes starting out with
trail running was a huge uh a huge uh
trick
that i had up my sleeve at this point
i'm able to put in some pretty serious
mileage on flat ground so i've kind of
uh
gotten past the the need to have a whole
lot of trail running but i still like to
mix it in from time to time have i ever
told you my one and only trail running
story did it end with a fall
uh
something arguably worse okay
so um
yeah
where i grew up there weren't many
trails there there was a lot of nature
but uh the only place within comfortable
driving distance that had trails was uh
was the park rich park
uh and and those
didn't seem to be particularly amenable
trails for running just because like
rich park is kind of built at the bottom
of a
top topographical bowl and so the whole
thing you're just running up and down
hill the whole time yeah um so when i
ran i would just always run on the the
little road where i grew up um it was
fine not much traffic uh so that was
always my approach um
so one time uh this guy abe
uh said hey i'm going trail running do
you want to come with me and i said okay
sure like i'll i'll roll the dice i'll
give it a shot uh so we went to ridge
park and uh went out started running
having a good time and then uh we're
going over
uh this bridge that's over this little
creek
and
i feel a very sudden sharp pain in the
bottom of my foot
there was uh there was an exposed nail
coming out of the bridge from where
where a board had pulled off and so i
had i had a rusty nail about two inches
up into the sole of my foot
uh and at this point
at this point we were
i mean rich park isn't big um so we we
weren't that far from the parking lot
but we were probably a good three
quarters of a mile from the parking lot
i would say uh not not three quarters of
a mile into the run but like you know as
the crow flies yeah um
and so anyway i
gingerly uh lifted my foot straight
vertically up off of the nail
um
and yeah i had to had to very gingerly
make my way back to the parking lot
and uh like i said the nail was very
rusty and so i'm sure it wasn't
particularly good for me and i
uh
i would say maybe like
three minutes into our little hobble
back to the parking lot i was faced with
a situ
uh scenario um because my foot was
starting to swell very quickly and so i
was just like
do i
keep my shoe on and just like compress
the [ __ ] out of my foot um
or like do i take my shoe off and try to
make it back again like walking through
the woods
already found one exposed nail like do i
want to make that trek barefoot
so anyway left the shoe on uh and you
know this these were just like standard
basketball shoes so like they had laces
but like there was so much pressure of
my foot against the inside of my shoe
that like it had tightened just like the
standard bow knot of my shoelaces enough
that it was challenging to get my
shoelaces undone
um
so anyway i had to go to the hospital to
make sure nothing too serious was going
on got another tetanus shot um anyway
haven't been trail running since yeah i
don't blame you so
look out for turning your ankle look out
for falling and look out for that as
well
results may vary
all right so uh moving on feats of
strength uh who is doing strong stuff uh
so i just have one this week and this is
uh
i think a very cool feat of strength
so uh bev francis recently stepped back
on the platform
um i don't think we've mentioned her in
feats of strength before there's a
reason for that uh she has not competed
in 36 years uh but she is back on the
platform at the spry age of 66. uh
competing in the six or uh competing at
62.5 kilograms or 138 pounds
she squatted 95 kilos benched 60 and
dead lifted 120 in pounds that's 209 132
and 264.
um
she won the meet in her age and weight
division which means that she is still
undefeated for her entire competitive
career so a little bit about that
competitive career
she previously competed from
1977 to 1985
in the process winning six consecutive
ipf world championships
she was also the first woman to ever
binge press over 300 pounds
um
which
is a huge milestone uh and i think at
the time she binge pressed 300 i think
the next heaviest female bench of all
time was like 260. so she was she was
way ahead of the field in her day
um
so yeah after she won her sixth
consecutive world championship uh she
basically i think decided like you know
what i've done enough in powerlifting
let's try something else uh so she got
into bodybuilding and uh
ended up the runner-up in the miss
olympia contest twice in 1990 and 1991
and uh
there is a story behind that 1991 uh
miss olympia that uh is on her wikipedia
page that you should go read sounds like
it sounds like a complete hose job um
in 1990 she had been told that she was
not quite big enough to
dethrone the winner linda murray
and so
like earlier in her career and her first
bodybuilding shows she had been told
that she was too big and then like the
judging standards of female bodybuilding
changed they started to reward more size
and so she was told in 1990 like oh
you're the runner-up because you're not
big enough so she said [ __ ] you guys i'm
gonna get i'm gonna get freaky huge and
so she she went out and put a lot of
muscle on her frame between 1990 and
1991. uh in 1991
was the first time that the miss olympia
had ever been live broadcast on espn
which that's very cool like early 90s uh
not only mr olympia but miss olympia on
espn
truly uh truly good times for the iron
sports so anyway it was on espn
and
she was
in the lead after
after pre-judging uh like leading up to
the night show
and
her understanding and the understanding
of everyone else was that
the night show
was was basically just a pageant like
you're getting up there
you're gonna flex you're gonna put on a
show for the audience but the winner had
already been selected because
that's apparently how it worked
um
so
she she fully expected that she already
had the win locked up uh but then
somehow out of nowhere she still ended
up getting second and linda murray beat
her again and the
speculation
is that since it was on espn um
there were maybe some prods from higher
up saying like you know what actually we
don't want to
reward mass
mass monsters in miss olympia because
maybe that's not going to be good for
viewership
um so that that's the
that's the speculation that exists
um
anyway she was
in addition to being a just a
groundbreaking power lifter she was an
excellent bodybuilder who for my money
should have won a miss olympia
um
and also before she got into either one
of those she held the australian
national record for the shot put throw
so
one of
the more impressive total careers of any
iron sport athlete ever
she's
i don't know if they're if there's
anyone else who is in both
the uh international powerlifting
federation hall of fame and the ifbb
hall of fame
uh if there is it's certainly not many
people she does hold that distinction uh
and then so you know after she got done
with bodybuilding because i i think
after that uh 1991 runner-up in the miss
olympia she basically just said you know
what [ __ ] it too much politics and
bodybuilding i'm done with this so then
she started a gym
it was previously a gold's gym and then
i think in 2005
it rebranded as powerhouse gym
but it's been called the east coast
mecca
as a as a kind of term of homage to the
mecca of bodybuilding gold's gym venice
um so it's
it's arguably the best bodybuilding gym
on the east coast so she
you know ran that for a long time um
and i mean so many great bodybuilders
have trained there and
i i have never been to
her powerhouse gym but
as i understand it it's absolutely
incredible
um so anyway i think she's retired from
that now and is just back home in
australia uh
just hanging out and getting back on the
power lifting platform so
still still very strong
for a woman her size and certainly a
woman her age
and like i said one of the most
decorated
uh
iron sport individuals that there's ever
been so
uh if you didn't know the name before
you know it now bev francis absolute
legend uh back where it all started back
on the powerlifting platform
and uh i don't know if you love to see
it but i love to see it
that's awesome you know i did recognize
the name bev francis from the gym i i
didn't understand uh the entire history
of her competitive career
and how decorated an athlete she is
i also can empathize with her
a lot of people were saying in 2017 when
i did my my first pro competition in
bodybuilding
that society wasn't ready for that kind
of muscularity and a lot of people are
saying i don't
i don't make this claim but i did get a
lot of letters and a lot of emails
saying that
if i wasn't so muscular i probably would
have secured the win so
i have been in her shoes and those are
not good shoes to be in
that is also why i haven't competed
since
it's just too frustrating
understandable uh okay so um
my hope for this episode
like i said this is airing on
thanksgiving day
many people will be busy watching
parades with floats and uh you know
football and eating turkey and stuff
like that
my hope is that this podcast will
accompany you on your travels home you
know after thanksgiving
you've probably gotten an argument with
your drunk relatives they probably
questioned all your life decisions very
critically
they probably argued with you about
politics on your ride home you just need
some stress relief and that's what we're
here for
we would never greg and i would never
question your life decisions we would
never argue with you about politics okay
so we're here to uh facilitate your
drive home or your flight home
uh
to uh
to transition to the next segment here
some nice easy listening what i want to
do is talk about mass a little bit more
this is a shameless promotion for the
sale we have going on but it's also good
content because mass content is
perfectly in line with what we do with
the podcast
so i mentioned earlier that we have a
free issue the best of mass issue
which you can download and you can read
to see if you like what's going what's
going on in the pages of mass
just to give you an idea of what you
might find in that issue
we've got improving muscle growth by
individualizing training volume that's
an article by greg
time to reframe the proximity to failure
conversation that's by zordos a
progression framework for hypertrophy a
very practical article by helms
modest glycogen depletion may impact
lifting performance more than you think
that is by me
ribosome biogenesis influences whether
high volumes cause more growth by greg
penalty reduction in gains for
interference an article by zordos about
the interference effect protein
distribution matters to an extent that's
by me
females fatigue slower than males
largely due to differences in blood flow
that's by you and then we got videos one
by zordos on volume cycling a very very
popular topic in the lifting world and a
video by helms translating nutrition
guidelines to life uh so a lot of
very practical information in there but
also articles on some more like cutting
edge topics like you know new findings
in the world of glycogen new findings in
the world of ribosome biogenesis so
that's what we try to do generally with
mass and in this episode of the podcast
we did want to take a little walk down
memory lane and talk about some of our
some of our favorite stuff from the last
year or so uh of mass writing so i was
brainstorming thinking through some of
my favorite stuff from the past year and
i know you're gonna share some uh some
more in-depth summaries of of your
favorites from the past year or so uh i
can't make this list without talking
about my article which was called does
getting lean make your next bulk more
effective
uh
little did we know yeah this article
that proved to be
uh
basically our entire content strategy
for two months more than two months
so so this article
was
kind of pushing back against the very
common recommendation that you know you
hear it from time to time in the
evidence-based fitness world that you
should get leaner before you bulk
that this would have potentially
positive effects on inflammation levels
or insulin sensitivity or any number of
factors that would lead your next bulk
to be more effective you'd be able to
gain a higher proportion of lean mass
and a lower relative proportion of fat
mass that is kind of the concept
in this mass article i kind of broke
down my reasoning
for why i didn't think the evidence
supports that contention
uh it
got you know people read it which is
good people commented about it uh people
tagged in their favorite fitness
influencers and evidence-based fitness
professionals and then
debates uh followed from there and then
several articles back and forth
rebuttals and
rebuttals to rebuttals and then
rebuttals to those yeah you can think of
of this mass article as the pre-bundle
to the rebuttal to the rebuttal exactly
yeah we were on jeff nippard's channel
had a round table that i thought was
really constructive uh with mike
israetel and meno henselmans so this was
an article that uh i loved writing it
because i think the topic is very
interesting
and i've always been quite skeptical of
the claim that you should get leaner in
order to make your next bulk more
efficient in terms of
lean tissue accretion so this article is
really where it all started
and we had some really
constructive and fruitful conversations
back and forth in the articles and the
debates that followed but ultimately uh
you know i think if you want to catch up
with that the the series of articles on
stronger by science.com were really nice
because they started with this core
argument which did hold up throughout
the the conversations back and forth but
because the arguments kept going further
and further we supplemented it with
those articles on stronger by
science.com we did our
basically our own little
non-systematic meta-analysis i guess
quasi-systematic meta-analysis where we
got individual participant level data to
look at how baseline body fat
influences uh you know success rates in
the following uh you know hypertrophy
focused training program and things like
that uh so man that was quite an
adventure and it all started in the
pages of mass
another series of articles i really
liked writing uh within the past year
was about
meal frequency and more specifically
looking at protein distribution so with
meal frequency back in the day
everybody's talking about meal frequency
uh within the context of if i eat more
meals per day will i speed up my
metabolism i feel like everybody at this
point has gotten off that particular
bandwagon and if anything is going the
other direction and now it's trendy to
have fewer meals right so it used to be
eight meals a day was really fashionable
now it's like one meal a day is really
fashionable
uh and in these articles i've talked
about you know how
empirically what seems to happen when we
increase from
two meals a day with sufficient protein
up to three meals a day with sufficient
protein or what happens when we increase
from three meals a day up to six meals
per day with sufficient protein and in
the context of writing these articles i
always felt that three high protein
meals a day was better than two
and in the course of writing these two
articles they largely confirmed that
particular perspective
when i say better i'm talking in terms
of supporting hypertrophy
and building muscle
what was interesting is i used to tell
people three to five meals a day is
probably the sweet spot in the process
of writing these articles uh the
evidence challenged that perspective and
suggested that three to six you know
three meals per day and six seem to be
fairly equivalent in terms of outcomes
so i used to cut it off and say three to
five uh it was harder to justify cutting
that off at five instead of six after
digging into some of this newer
literature and ultimately that's what
mass is all about it it's about looking
at the newer evidence as it comes in and
continuing to update recommendations and
prior beliefs you know so
uh that's my favorite thing about being
a contributor to mass is that
we literally have to stay on top of the
literature like we don't have a choice
we can't rest on our laurels and say
nope i made my recommendations in 2013
and those are in stone you know which is
something that you kind of do see like
there are some people who haven't really
revisited uh their kind of standard
recommendations for quite some time uh
so yeah that was one article that made
me really question some of those
pre-formed
recommendations
now
another series of articles that has
become more and more important to me
over time is i wrote a couple articles
about vegan diets one was a shorter term
study that was you know heavily
supplemented with mycoprotein looking at
muscle protein synthesis rates over
several days
and that's an important uh consideration
so in these mass articles
we sometimes when it's useful
get into some of the nitty-gritty
details about methodology and one of the
things i've said on the show previously
is that sometimes people get a little
bit too
excited about extrapolating muscle
protein synthesis results to hypertrophy
over time but it's important to
recognize that there are some muscle
protein synthesis studies that are more
applicable or more generalizable than
others so when you're looking at muscle
protein synthesis rates over a long
stretch of observation time so over days
rather than hours that can increase the
generalizability when you're trying to
make inferences about hypertrophy
another aspect is training status and
doing unaccustomed exercise so if you're
doing something that's totally
unaccustomed
you know if you're untrained and you go
through a brutal exercise bout and
they're looking at muscle protein
synthesis rates over the next four hours
it is very very difficult to make a
strong case that that's going to
correlate well with hypertrophy but if
you're looking at rates over several
days with a less extreme exercise
protocol that's not quite as
unaccustomed now you're getting closer
to making some some generalizable
inferences uh so the first paper i wrote
in this series was looking at muscle
protein synthesis over a few days and
that vegan diet which was supplemented
with a lot of mycoprotein which is a
fungi derived protein source uh funny
story is they used to say it comes from
mushrooms and then somebody was like
dude that just absolutely doesn't come
from mushrooms and then they're like
okay okay okay it comes from fungus
sorry uh but yeah they got in trouble
for that but anyway uh that vegan diet
as long as protein was high enough
and as long as
as as i already mentioned meal
distribution and protein distribution
was sufficient as long as you're getting
three or four at least
high quality uh you know
uh servings of protein the vegan diet
and the omnivorous diet
you know the results were quite
comparable quite similar
but i still wasn't
totally sufficiently convinced because
again we're talking about a few days of
muscle protein synthesis we're not
talking about 12 weeks of hypertrophy
then
the next study comes along a few issues
later
where they actually did look at
hypertrophy
at multiple different levels
you know lean body mass they looked at
cross-sectional area of the muscles
themselves they looked at hypertrophy at
several different levels
12-week intervention resistance training
with uh either an omnivorous diet or a
vegan diet that was supplemented this
time with soy protein which i was stoked
about because now we're not saying it
has to be myco protein now we're just
talking about any reasonably high
quality vegan protein source that's
helping people achieve a sufficient
intake of protein you know so we're
talking about 1.6 1.8 grams per kilogram
per day within this context and once
again the vegan diet
uh had very comparable results compared
to the omnivorous diet as long as both
of them had plenty of protein
and as long as protein distribution was
suitable so those two articles i thought
were really
meaningful because we've all you know
the the standard recommendation is like
well you can you can do vegan or
vegetarian but man that's going to be an
uphill battle you have to make some
really huge uh concessions or really
huge modifications to ensure adequacy of
that diet for muscle building purposes
the newer research along those lines is
indicating the opposite that those you
know vegan and omnivorous diets within
those uh those parameters i mentioned
are probably more comparable than we've
been treating them in the past
would you refer to this line of research
as a game changer
perhaps i would but who could possibly
pay the copyright fees
no but
it is uh i i did make a game changer pun
in one of the titles uh it was it was
vegan diets not a game changer for
hypertrophy but a viable alternative and
ultimately that was one of the things
going all the way back man that was like
was that like season one the game
changer stuff i i think it probably was
uh my whole thing with game changers i
considered making a more direct
reference to that to that content arc
but i was like uh
without some context
who knows how many of our readers will
will get a nocturnal emissions reference
but yeah
that's true anyway and it's thanksgiving
vegan diets they're gonna make your
muscles big in your dick hard that's
right
i think that's the takeaway yeah so uh
that was my whole thing with game
changers like dude you could have you
could have just made an argument that
these are very viable alternatives but
they had to take it that other step and
be like dude you will never have a
minute of sleep with a flaccid penis
again if you adopt a vegan diet i'm like
why do you have to do this you know or
dude you're gonna set so many world
records if you have everything about
your diet the same but it's just vegan
instead of omnivorous and it's like
dude no one believes that no one thinks
that's true
like i don't know why why that would
have to be the argument
but anyway
another uh topic that we we cover
frequently in mass especially the last
year or so
is
the role of carbohydrate for the lifter
and
this is an interesting area and it gets
more interesting as lower carbohydrate
approaches become more and more popular
so
keto got really big in for lifters i'd
say probably like 2012 2013 2014. seems
about right so there's there is a minute
there where everybody was really
interested in it many people tried it i
know i did i believe you did as well oh
yeah i was keto for like a year and a
half yeah i was keto for i think about
half of a year
um which apparently is one week too
short to get the real adaptation going
uh and you also were probably about a
week short as well i would assume
i so i actually uh
i was
mostly keto in the run-up to my first uh
my first powerlifting world records
actually nice um
you could have marketed that hard so i i
did start eating carbs again
maybe like a month two months out from
the meat
uh but anyway then i did my entire next
training cycle with
carbs and uh
got a lot stronger and set more world
records so
i don't really think the presence or
absence of carbs really made that much
of a difference yeah and that's really
been the the real heart of the issue
when it comes to carbs and how we
discuss it in mass
and helms and i have had a bunch of
really constructive peer reviews so when
we write an article for mass
all of the authors peer review it and
sometimes you know we will get into
extremely heated highly personal
arguments that involve a lot of uh
a lot of name calling a lot of insults
and so helms and i have gone back and
forth on the carb articles but
ultimately the question is how much does
a lifter really need them
and you know in what context
and we've covered a lot of keto articles
in mass
we've covered a lot of articles that
discuss
when
to have carbs and how much you know how
much carbohydrate to consume for the
typical lifter and generally speaking
that you know the arguments come back to
the fact that
as a lifter
uh if you're doing stuff
in the kind of more hypertrophy focused
rep range or higher you know if you're
doing if you're doing sets of three in
sets of five and that's making up the
basis of your training
you probably
don't need a huge influx of carbohydrate
to get through a training
to a workout or a training program so
when you tell me that you had a really
successful meat prep while doing keto
that doesn't surprise me in the
slightest just because your training did
not tax you know the glycolytic energy
system to a significant degree oh yeah i
was doing that was the meet where i was
doing like bulgarian style training in
the lead up so a lot of singles a lot of
singles uh and if i did a set of three i
was just like ah that's too much i'm
doing doubles tomorrow yeah
so yeah in that context it's like
you know there's really not much of a
physiological rationale to suggest that
you need a really high amount of
carbohydrate um but when it gets into
hey i'm doing a more hypertrophy focused
program lots of eights lots of tens lots
of twelves or if you're doing something
like crossfit and you're just going
crazy with the glycolytic energy
production in those contexts you know
we've got a lot of articles that have
gone into how much carbohydrate would be
needed when it would be needed
and there have been some really
fascinating studies about that
within the past year or so
but we don't just focus on carbs another
thing we've talked about in the past
year is
fat restriction and how that impacts
testosterone levels
and man that is a really tricky
conversation to have because
you look at this literature right and
there's plenty of studies indicating
that if we do
relatively uh i mean not super severe
fat restriction if we're talking about
going from like 40 of calories from fat
down to 20
that's like a fairly standard approach
with some of these studies looking at
the effects of fat restriction or maybe
35 to 15 we're not talking about going
on like a a three percent fat diet or
anything like that
and what's really fascinating is these
studies do tend to show a reduction in
testosterone and other related uh
androgenic hormones right other
androgens uh
but what's tricky is trying to sort
through
you know what is the perfect diet for
testosterone if we assume that that it
actually matters all that much which is
a completely separate assumption but
there's research showing that really
extreme carb restriction can negatively
impact testosterone there's research
showing that really extreme fat
restriction can also negatively impact
testosterone and there's just studies
showing that simply reducing calories in
general uh will will reduce testosterone
and studies showing that simply having a
high ratio of protein to other stuff in
your diet reduces testosterone which is
essentially the same thing as saying
carb or fat restriction or little of
both so it gets really challenging when
you try to sort through those details
and say what exactly is driving these
reductions in testosterone but one of
the things i focus on in that particular
line of articles whenever i talk about
fat and testosterone or testosterone
boosters my big question is what what do
you want this testosterone to be doing
you know so how much
the types of fluctuations in
testosterone that we see for example
in studies on testosterone boosting
herbal ingredients for example
the magnitude of effect is really
nowhere near large enough in the data
that we've seen up to this point to
suggest that it would meaningfully
impact strength or hypertrophy or
anything like that i think the most you
could maybe hope for with those types of
ingredient you know dietary supplements
to to enhance testosterone or
macronutrient modifications to enhance
testosterone the most you could really
hope for is if you're kind of at the low
end of the normal range maybe getting a
little bit of a boost that would get you
to a spot where you feel other benefits
of higher testosterone things like
your just general energy level
subjectively or your libido for example
i think that stuff is feasible but when
it comes to strength and hypertrophy i
think a lot of the
really nuanced worrying about
testosterone management within the
physiological range is probably not
particularly constructive not not the
type of thing i'd spend a lot of time on
now one exception to that
if you have extremely low energy
availability and your testosterone is
tanking
you can very meaningfully reverse that
through uh various dietary interventions
which all point in the same direction
which is you got to have more energy
available
in that case you can see people go from
the high end of the normal range
throughout a bodybuilding prep go down
to testosterone levels that are
so low i mean when you look at some of
the case reports or if you do a
bodybuilding prep and you get your blood
work done
i don't know what my normal test is i've
never checked it when things are good i
only check it when things are bad
but you know i've heard of people who go
from like 700 to like 110
over the course of a bodybuilding prep
and it's really not all that unusual so
in that case
that's a big change like i i think that
matters uh and i think correcting that
energy deficiency uh is a very
straightforward approach to rectifying
that and i think the impact is huge uh
but for not huge but it's meaningful
it's tangible
for everything else you know those
interventions that claim to bump your
testosterone from
350 to 385
i don't think you can do a whole lot
with that
uh
that brings me to you know one of the
topics that comes up a lot in mass
especially in my articles is uh you know
we talk about a lot of dietary
supplements
and uh just looking back over the last
year or so
i've covered ginseng i've covered
diascoria escalenta testosterone
boosters cbd oil twice
creatine caffeine dietary nitrate
vitamin d alpha lactalbumin pre and
probiotics hibiscus tea
kind of treated as a dietary supplement
in a way
even though it technically is just a
beverage right but uh we get into a lot
of dietary supplements some of which are
quite common and so you see them on the
page and say oh maybe i'll learn
something new about you know
an everyday supplement that has a lot of
name recognition but also i try to look
at some of these other supplements that
are lesser known you know and see hey
should this be on your radar or not
uh two of the supplements that i've
talked about recently in mass
um
really fascinate me and they are
they're not yet at a spot where i would
enthusiastically recommend them
but they are on my radar you know
they're kind of uh i'm keeping an eye on
them one of them is
capsi8 or other capsaicinoids so
compounds that are structurally
quite similar to capsaicin which is what
basically makes hot peppers very hot
and the other one is betaine and betaine
we've written about that in stronger by
science we had a whole article about it
so the capsaicin literature is
fascinating there's now been paper
showing
enhancements in training volume
enhancements in
strength endurance enhancements in
force like maximal force production and
better training adaptations in a
longitudinal trial so better increases
in i believe
fat free mass and i believe bench press
one rep max as well so
that alone when you talk about those
findings spread across four different
studies that's enough to get your
attention especially for a supplement
that does not have a lot of research in
general but one of the issues that i've
talked about is the fact that we just
need a lot of replication a lot of that
research is coming from the same exact
lab group which is studying this
basically the same exact study
population every single time and we talk
about in science how important
replication is but we also like to see
independent replication uh in a variety
of different contexts and populations
that helps us to really understand what
a supplement can and can't do so capsi8
and other capsaicinoids are on my radar
they've been written about in mass
several times now
but i'm not quite ready to give them the
official stamp of approval
another thing that's interesting about
capsaicinoids is their impact slight
impact on thermogenesis and hunger
regulation so
capsaicinoids there's a decent amount of
evidence suggesting that they could have
a slight impact on reducing hunger
reducing desire to eat and increasing
energy expenditure in the short window
after they're consumed so it's quite a
fascinating supplement
and then betaine
it's another one that's just on my radar
you know uh we've talked about this in
the stronger by science article
uh
there are plausible mechanisms there is
mixed evidence
there's certainly some evidence showing
benefits for body composition and
performance plenty of evidence showing
uh no significant benefit
and it is one of those bodies of
literature where you're like you're just
waiting for a pattern to truly form i
still think they need to test higher
doses i i fully agree uh and it's one of
the things i tiptoed into in my
conclusions the last time i wrote about
betaine because
i want to be careful there i don't want
to tell people like hey go use a
completely experimental dose that you
have no idea how you're going to react
to it uh
that's probably not the best way to do
it
rather i i'd like research that's
exactly how i would do it i know it is
but for the purposes of the podcast it's
not a recommendation
and uh what i'd like to see is
researchers kind of breaking out of the
standard mold for these studies which is
usually 2.5 grams a day always every
time
and you know mixed findings what i'd
like to see is some higher doses because
one of the things that we've pointed out
in that betaine article a while ago is
betaine is often used in livestock
applications so trying to increase meat
yield
and in some cases reduce subcutaneous
fat storage in a variety of different
livestock uh
models right so so there's research in
chickens there's research in pigs i'm
not sure if i've seen research in cattle
but i think most of it is in pigs yeah a
lot of it is in pigs for sure
and uh the thing about livestock is like
dude you don't want to waste a lot of
money on nonsense food additives like
that's that's a serious thing uh when
you talk about just the general scale of
a livestock operation there's not a lot
of wiggle room there to just be
frivolously throwing around food
additives that are costly that aren't
actually being beneficial in terms of
yield and so uh it's funny because the
term they use
i've read way too much agriculture
research because of betaine the term
that they often use is performance
which is basically just like yeah that
was
we raised that particular animal well uh
to have a high meat yield and it
performed well for our purposes right
but it would always throw me when i
would read it like it's a study about
pigs and it's like yeah performance
improved i'm like what were they doing
you know like i think it like a little
pig race or something like some kind of
get them on a little pig treadmill with
a mask like dude vo2 is up eight percent
yeah huge performance enhancement but um
but anyway yeah it's just really
difficult and that alone is not a
sufficient uh
argument right you can't just say well
farmers use it i'm sure it's good but it
is something that you're like man but
the doses they use are much higher
and
farmers in many cases seem to be quite
committed to betaine as an additive and
it seems to work across multiple species
including pigs which are
not a bad model like if when it comes to
animal models pigs are
pigs are often as close as we get before
we start doing a human trial you know so
i agree with you i'd like to see more
higher dose research there but uh you
know the the capsaicin stuff and the
betaine stuff caused me to put together
my
uh my supplement tier system just to
help me kind of organize my thoughts uh
and so that that's a mass exclusive or
an original
but right now i consider both of them to
be a tier three supplement which is you
know there's insufficient evidence at
this time to conclusively determine
their efficacy so that that means we
can't definitively say that they do work
for a given purpose but we also struggle
to to definitively say that they don't
work for a purpose
so
tier 5 is the worst and that means that
there's sufficient evidence to conclude
that the supplement either harms health
or harms performance so tier five you
want nothing to do with and then tier
one basically indicates that there is
very strong evidence
to support reliable and meaningful
effects practically meaningful so tier
one is is rarefied air we're talking
about creatine when it comes to strength
and performance we're talking about
protein supplements only if they're
getting you to an adequate protein
intake but there's not a lot of stuff
going on at tier one but uh anyway
that's my rundown of some of my favorite
observations favorite pieces of content
from the last year or so of mass and
greg i know you've got a few uh that you
enjoyed as well yeah how how far into
this recording are we i'm debating
whether i want to do all three of these
or just two
uh it's up to you uh you know because i
can trim all the stuff after it's
whatever you want to do
we're less than an hour in but getting
close to an hour okay all right
people have a long journey home for
their thanksgiving so yeah i also got a
lot of a lot of stuff to do today yeah
all right uh this is very very
professional uh podcasting as we
discussed i don't really have time for
this you know what this is thanksgiving
week uh we also have holidays we observe
i
never take three days off but i'm about
to so i'm i'm just trying to get a lot
of [ __ ] done today i hear you do as many
as you like let's see what happens all
right so um yeah there were
there were a lot of studies this past
year that i that i found interesting uh
but i pulled out kind of three areas uh
to elaborate on a little bit more um
that hopefully you guys find interesting
so this first one um
one of the one of my
more recent hobby horses within the last
like six months or so
is uh
looking at the effects of range of
motion on hypertrophy um
because i there's a lot of
i i mean there has been for several
years a lot of just like chatter in the
evidence-based fitness community about
how
full range of motion training through a
full range of motion is very important
for hypertrophy
and i kind of don't think that full
range of motion matters all that much
i think that when people talk about the
benefits of full range of motion
training for muscle growth i think
ultimately they're just picking up on
the benefits of ensuring that your reps
do include the portion of the rep that
involves uh muscular tension and long
muscle links but i don't think the range
of motion is all that important per se
so for example um
if you're doing something that has a
where full range of motion is 120
degrees at a particular joint
i think that the benefits of training
through a full range of motion rather
than a partial range of motion
is that when people talk about partials
they tend to just be talking about the
top half of the range of motion so for
example if you're doing bench press
you lock the bar out between every rep
but you only go midway down to your
chest
so when people talk about partials they
think about something like that or like
half squats for example
and so when you're using that as your
model of partial range of motion
training what you do tend to find is
that full range of motion training uh
improves outcomes so training all the
way from zero degrees of flexion to 120.
uh but i i kind of think that if you
just train from 120 degrees to 60
degrees and cut out the top part kind of
the classic um
uh constant tension training approach i
think that's just as good as training
through a full range of motion
because ultimately i think it's less
that just the total angular displacement
at each joint matters and it's more so
ensuring that you are training through
the part with long muscle links and i
kind of think the part where you're
training through short muscle lengths um
you know just has a neutral effect so
whether or not you lock out each rep
doesn't really matter all that much so
with uh with that introduction out of
the way i reviewed uh
two studies in mass this past year that
are directly relevant to that
uh so the title of the first one was
partial range of motion training might
increase muscle growth parentheses if
you do the right type of partials so
this was a study by pedrosa and
colleagues the title was partial range
of motion training elicits favorable
improvements in muscular adaptations
when carried out at long muscle lengths
um so in this study uh
five groups of untrained women uh
completed a 12-week training protocol uh
one of the groups was a non-training
control group and then the other four
groups
trained knee extensions for 12 weeks so
one of the groups did all of their reps
through a full range of motion
one of the groups did all of their reps
through a partial range of motion
in a
decent bit of knee flexion so basically
the bottom half of the range of motion
which
coincides with long muscle lengths for
the quadriceps
one group did partials but just through
the top half of the range of motion so
the part of the range of motion that
would have uh that would be through
short muscle lengths of the quadriceps
one group did varied partial range of
motion so they did half of their reps
partials at long muscle links half of
them partials at short muscle lengths
and the final group was uh just a full
range of motion group where they you
know did full range of motion reps uh so
they trained for 12 weeks and they
looked at growth of the vastus lateralis
and rectus femoris at
three different sites so or four
different sites so from a proximal site
at forty percent of femur length so
that's uh if you go from the hip to the
knee uh starting at the hip going down
40 of femur length that was the most
proximal site and then 70 percent of
femur length so closer to the knee that
was the most distal site
um
so yeah uh
there were i mean there there were a
shitload of pairwise comparisons here
but the the broad strokes are that
um
the
partial range of motion at long muscle
lengths group had overall the best
hypertrophy response uh of all of the
four training groups and and certainly
better than the control group
um
but but that group the full range of
motion group and the variable range of
motion partial group
all had pretty solid hypertrophy
outcomes the partial range of motion
group just training at short muscle
links
tended to grow quite a bit less than the
other three groups particularly in the
distal parts of the muscle so
the 40 and 50 percent of femur link
sites the more the more proximal parts
tended to grow pretty well in all of the
groups but then the more distal sites
tended to grow the best in the three
groups that did involve training at long
muscle links
and like i mentioned the
group that just did partials at long
muscle lengths got at least as good of
hypertrophy results as any of the other
groups and arguably better than any of
the other groups so that that was some
uh
direct evidence that the range of motion
through which you're training partials
matters a lot and that if you're doing
the partials at long muscle links they
may actually produce slightly more
hypertrophy than training just through a
full range of motion
and then there was a
a more recent study
by
sato and colleagues that i just reviewed
last month elbow joint angles and elbow
flexor unilateral resistance exercise
training determine its effects
on muscle strength and thickness of
trained and non-trained arms so in this
study subjects did unilateral preacher
curls
there wasn't a full range of motion
group in this study it was just partials
at long muscle links versus partials at
short muscle links uh and subjects were
doing unilateral preacher curls
and and the findings were very similar
so they had three different measurement
sites here uh 50 60 and 70 of humorous
length
overall hypertrophy was greater in the
group doing partials at long muscle
lengths in the group doing partials at
short muscle links
and the magnitude of difference
increased as you moved towards more
distal sites along the muscle
um and then when averaging all three
sites together the group doing the lung
the long muscle length partials
experience like 2.6 times more
hypertrophy than the group doing short
muscle length partials
so again not a direct comparison in that
study to full range of motion training
but
very clear evidence that not all
partials are created equal
partials at short muscle links tend to
not cause as much growth overall and in
particular there's a pretty big
difference at distal muscle sites so
like for example if you wanted uh and
and this is going to depend to some
degree on like tendon length and overall
muscle architecture but kind of like in
a vacuum if you just want like a big
like freaky horseshoe tricep that hangs
over your elbow or just like big freaky
quads that like
look like they're about to swallow up
your knees uh those are distal muscle
sites and and training through long
muscle links tends to be very important
for growth in those sites
and there's also uh
more evidence just from isometric
training that you know not even doing
reps but just tension per se at long
muscle links
tends to promote uh hypertrophy quite
well so there was a a systematic review
by oren chuck and colleagues i think in
2019
uh isometric training and long-term
adaptations effects of muscle length
intensity and intent a systematic review
and one of the things they looked at in
that systematic review was isometric
training at long versus short muscle
links finding that
hypertrophy tended to be quite a bit
greater when you did isometric training
at long muscle lengths than short
and there there's also evidence i think
that
uh
including the part of the range of
motion that coincides with short
muscling so essentially locking out
every rep um
maybe doesn't matter all that much and
could potentially be
slightly harmful for hypertrophy uh and
i think that probably depends on
whether kind of the lockout position
does
keep you under tension or not but there
was a study by goto and colleagues um
looking at triceps growth with uh
partial range of motion versus full
range of motion uh barbell tricep
extensions basically skull crushers
one of the groups trained through a full
range of motion so from zero to 120
degrees of elbow flexion one of the
groups
did partials just through the mid-range
of motion so
at the bottom they stopped at 90 degrees
of elbow flexion and then they went up
to 45 degrees of elbow flexion but they
didn't actually lock the reps out
and in that study
i
they didn't assess hypertrophy i think
in the most
using using gold standard methods they
used a regression equation based on uh
arm circumferences and skin fold
thicknesses which
so it's been done but yeah it's it's not
the best way to assess hypertrophy so
take it with a slight grain of salt but
they they did find that
estimates of tricep cross-sectional area
derived from arm circumference and skin
fold thicknesses
increased to to a greater extent in the
group that basically skipped lockout
even though they didn't actually go down
as far
into elbow flexion on each rep so i
think that
when you kind of triangulate all of that
um
i would definitely like to see
more direct comparisons uh specifically
between
long muscle length partials and full
range of motion before i could make any
sort of definitive statement
because currently we do just have one
study making that direct direct
comparison um and it's looking at just
single joint exercises in untrained
individuals so
you know you probably don't want to put
too many eggs in that basket but i think
that there are
several different lines of evidence that
one could point to to to say that
you know at worst
um
partials through a longer partials uh at
in in long muscle length positions
rather than short muscle length
positions uh
i think you can say at worst that's
going to cause more hypertrophy than
partials just through short muscle
length positions you know
kind of for now discounting the
comparison to full range of motion
training so i think we can very
confidently say not all partials are
created equal
um but i do i do kind of think that
uh if you do like quote unquote constant
tension training you do partials but the
part of the range of motion you're
cutting out is like the lockout portion
the short muscle length portion uh
i kind of think that you're going to
grow just as much as you would from
doing full range of motion training and
possibly slightly more
and another thing i'll note is that when
when we talk about
when we talk about the effects of range
of motion on hypertrophy i think it's
also
worth nuancing that just a little bit
so the the differences don't seem to be
um kind of evenly dispersed across the
length of a muscle so if you compare
kind of quote unquote normal partial
range of motion training so you know now
we're talking half squats bench presses
that don't touch your chest etc
when we look at that type of partial
compared to
either long muscle length partials or
full range of motion training in studies
that assess hypertrophy at multiple
different muscle sites what they tend to
find is that for more proximal muscle
sites
you actually seem to grow about the same
amount regardless of range of motion so
you know if you're assessing changes in
quad size closer to the hip or changes
in
tricep size closer to the shoulder for
example
seems like those proximal sites tend to
grow pretty well
regardless of how you're training but
that uh either partials at long muscle
links or full range of motion training
that includes training at long muscle
links that tends to be pretty essential
for fully growing more distal parts of
the muscle so
overall full range of motion training
does beat short muscle length partials
but the
the uh
effects aren't evenly distributed across
the muscle there there is that regional
component which
i personally think is kind of cool
yeah i mean i suspect that some
people at my gym kind of suspect that
i'm a dumb ass uh and the reason is
i think
i think some people
struggle to warm up to the idea of
partials at short uh i'm sorry partials
at long muscle lengths they also think
you're a dumb ass because you thought
that
simply the fact that a magnet wouldn't
stick to you immediately after you got a
vaccine
negated their argument that vaccines
would stick to you immediately after you
got a vaccine i'm not sure if we ever
actually mentioned that on the show we
did for sure okay
so that that's a throwback uh at first i
was like i don't think anyone has
context for that no but um i think some
people struggle to warm up to this idea
of partials at long muscle lengths
because
back in the day you would call that
cheating right so like for example a lot
of times i'll be doing bicep curls this
is one of the areas where i use a little
bit of this but i'll do full range of
motion bicep curls until i can no longer
and then i will do a few extra reps at
the end of doing partial range of motion
and it'll be up to that sticking point
which is you know i'm training
exclusively at longer
muscle lengths for for those partials
and so i think the the typical person
passing by would say look at this
jackass who's counting these reps and
he's like not even getting halfway up uh
but it's it's intentional uh and i think
you know like you said i i don't know if
it's necessarily doing too much but like
it's a nice little supplementary thing
to help me get a little bit more effort
into that set is it going to pay off big
time i don't know but i do similar
things uh depending on you know what i'm
trying to accomplish in the set but
sometimes i'll do similar things for
like a dumbbell incline press i'll do
full range of motion until i'm kind of
struggling uh at that kind of sticking
point in the middle then i'll get some
nice loaded stretches i'll keep
everything at the longer muscle lengths
for my pecs and get a few extra reps to
really uh to really grind out the set
and so i think the typical passerby
would say those reps don't count that
guy's a jackass but then
i take off my top layer and i'm wearing
a stringer and they say holy [ __ ]
that looks like the kind of guy that is
so muscular
that it would hold him back at the
professional bodybuilding level even
have been able to win the 1991 miss
olympia they would have given it to
someone less muscular that's what they
think so but when i'm not when i'm not
wearing a stringer and i have bulky
clothing on i don't think they can tell
you know but anyway i use a little bit
of this partial range of motion stuff
and it's pretty nice i like it sweet
uh the the area where where i've always
used it is uh dumbbell flies like i've
talked about my love of the pec deck
machine on this podcast several times
before but i'm training in my basement
now uh you know just have dumbbells
don't have a pec deck don't have room
for a pec deck if i did i'd definitely
get a peck dad uh but anyway i
do you don't need a whole kitchen just
get rid of part of your kitchen and put
it on absolutely not um but yeah i know
so i i like peck training i think that
um
i think that i'm the only maybe the only
person in the world who has a pec
dominant pull-up like when you're when
your arms are when your arms are above
your head
your pecs do have slight shoulder
extension functionality and uh
when i'm
good at pull-ups like when i've been
doing pull-ups somewhat frequently and i
can do a decent number in a set
i always get an enormous peck pump from
pull-ups like i i think i get a a bigger
pec pump than lat pump um
anyway i i think that just about every
upper body exercise i do somehow turns
out to be peck dominant uh so i i like
peck training i just think it's fun
and so when i do dumbbell flies
i and
i'm man this goes back to when i was
like 12 years old and i was first
introduced to the exercise
um
like i was doing like full range of
motion dumbbell pec flies on a bench in
the local ymca
um
and this older gentleman comes up to me
he said
you want me to teach you how to do flies
and this guy i think i may have
mentioned him on the podcast before he
was one of my first training partners i
had two very fun training partners at
that ymca one of them was this guy i'm
about to mention the other one was a
bounty hunter and um
his name wasn't dog was it his name
i [ __ ] you this wasn't his real name but
everyone referred to him as cornbread
cornbread the bounty hunter
[Laughter]
uh if we ever do merchandise we have to
have a cornbread the bounty hunter
character yeah uh anyway both excellent
training partners they taught me a lot
and also they both had uh excellent
stories but anyway um
[Music]
completely neglecting the stories for
now
this was this was my first introduction
to this older gentleman
and he was in his
either late 60s or early 70s but still
had
a he he still had a very solid physique
um
and yeah he he he could tell that i
didn't really know what i was doing so
he's like you want me to teach you how
to really do peck flies and i said okay
sure absolutely i i would love to learn
uh
and so
he i think one of the reasons why i'm
kind of open to the whole idea of long
muscle length partials is that's all
this guy did um
like you know he he would do he would do
weighted pull-ups again like in his late
60s early 70s he'd have like a either a
plate or a plate and a 25 hanging off of
him but he'd only do like a seven inch
range of motion like by the time the top
of his head was level with the bar he
was done concentric was over time to go
back down i actually liked that as well
uh and he he approached everything the
same way so like you know he'd do
dumbbell press go all the way down at
the bottom
push it up about four inches go back
down like that that's how he approached
all of his training um so anyway he
taught me that method of pec flies like
go down until you get a deep stretch
go up
until
like you still feel a lot of tension on
the muscle but it's not acutely
stretched anymore and then just go back
down so we're talking pec flies through
maybe a six inch range of motion yeah
and
like i've done flies before because i'd
seen them in a magazine and someone big
said this is a good exercise uh
but like that was the first time that
the next day my pecs felt
absolutely destroyed i was like hell
yeah this is how i do flies now and i've
always done that like i i never go all
the way up on flies um and i think that
that's probably in a pretty extreme
example
just because the mechanical leverage is
so low at the bottom and so high at the
top but i think a similar principle
can apply to most exercises you do
um
god that guy was an excellent training
partner as well uh
becau
no never mind i'm not telling that story
yeah
okay he he did a lot of things that
could probably get him canceled in 2021
that were
i guess fine in 2006. yeah uh yeah so
let's let's move on a little bit okay uh
let's talk about inner the interference
effect and concurrent training a little
bit let's do it um the road to athens
segment of the last podcast was a hit
there were
multiple people and and by that i mean
two or potentially three people
uh who asked for more concurrent
training content on the podcast
uh so is that a representative sample of
our listeners probably not but let's uh
let's meet their needs right now let's
do it
uh so
the title of the article i wrote was
does the interference effect get larger
as training status increases title of
the study i reviewed was development of
maximal dynamic strength during
concurrent resistance and endurance
training in untrained moderately trained
and trained individuals a systematic
review and meta-analysis by petrie and
colleagues
um
so in in this uh meta-analysis
i mean you you can probably tell what
they did just from the title uh they
started with a systematic literature
search they uh identified studies with
um
healthy subjects between 18 and 40 years
old um
the group the studies needed to compare
a group performing uh both lower body
resistance training and endurance
training versus a group doing an
identical resistance training program
but no endurance training
the subjects all needed to have the same
training status
resistance training needed to occur at
least twice per week at uh a 10 at an
intensity of at least 60 percent of 1rm
uh the endurance training needed to
uh at least be of moderate intensity um
so not like walking programs or anything
like that uh and the studies needed to
report changes in maximal squat or leg
press strength those were the inclusion
criteria they found 27 studies um
all of which were judged to be of either
moderate to high quality uh seven seven
studies were on untrained subjects ten
were on moderately trained subjects
and uh ten were on trained subjects i'll
note that i don't necessarily agree with
the
the researchers characterization of
untrained versus moderately trained in
this study so
they categorized a study as being on
moderately trained subjects
if the subjects um
were reported as being active
so
you'd only be counted as untrained if
they reported that like people were
completely sedentary if someone was
described as recreationally active but
not participating in resistance training
they'd still count them as moderately
trained for this meta-analysis
i don't necessarily agree with that but
uh yeah because i mean a lot of times
for studies that are sampling like uh
college students for example which is a
huge percentage of studies it's like ah
you're a college student you go to class
every day you know maybe you play
kickball twice a week you're not really
trained yeah yeah yeah yeah so uh i
functionally just view it as train
versus untrained i i don't like the the
untrained versus moderately trained
distinction that they made in this study
uh but anyway that's what they did
that's the nomenclature i'll use moving
forward uh so just be aware that when i
say moderately trained i'm talking
untrained but but fairly active
so anyway they ran the meta three
different ways um
first they just looked at all effect
sizes from all studies
second they looked at uh just studies
where
the endurance and resistance training
were performed in the same session so
you know you show up at the gym you run
for 30 minutes and then you lift or you
show up at the gym you lift and then you
run for 30 minutes
all in one session
and then the third way they ran it was
just looking at studies where
the endurance and resistance training
took place in different sessions so they
could have been on different days they
could have been
on the same day but like you lift in the
morning run in the evening or vice versa
so they looked at it in in those uh
three different ways
so in in their first meta analysis when
it was just all effect sizes from all
studies they found that for untrained
subjects
concurrent training led to
strength gains that were just as large
as only doing resistance training
for moderately trained subjects there
also wasn't a statistically significant
effect but there was an effect size of
0.2 p-value of 0.08 uh favoring
resistance training only for strength
gains and then for trained subjects
there was a there was a significant
effect small effect size uh cohen's d
0.35 and that was statistically
significant so basically you see this
pattern where
the magnitude of the interference effect
or stated another way the superiority of
just doing resistance training versus
concurrent training
got
larger and larger as training status
increased such that there was virtually
no effect for sedentary individuals and
a
small but statistically significant
effect for trained individuals so moving
on in the studies where endurance and
resistance training were performed in
the same training session a similar
pattern emerged but the effect sizes
were larger particularly for the trained
subjects so for untrained individuals
again virtually no effect
for moderately trained subjects you see
a
small to trivial effect again cohen's d
of 0.23 and again not quite
statistically significant p-value 0.14
but then for the trained subjects you
you're seeing now a pretty notable
effect size of 0.66
that's generally termed a moderate
effect
not quite bordering on a large effect
which is typically
typically going to be 0.8 uh with with
the standard cutoffs but that's that's a
relatively hefty moderate effect um so
especially for trained subjects when
you're doing concurrent training with
both uh endurance training and lifting
in the same session there seems to be a
pretty negative effect on strength
outcomes uh
that's not to say you'll get weaker you
will continue getting stronger but
probably at a notably slower rate than
you would have if you were just lifting
and not doing endurance training
and then finally
when they
just looked at studies where endurance
and resistance training were
performed in separate sessions either
separate times on the same day or on
different days they actually found no
significant effect regardless of
training status so
it seemed that just separating out the
stimuli
basically completely did away with the
interference effect such that concurrent
training was just as effective for
strength development as only doing
strength training was
so i'll note i do think that um
in a meta-analysis like this where we're
basically you're just looking at
two training variables like did you just
lift weights or did you lift weights and
also do cardio you're missing out on
some degree of nuance like you're you're
not you're basically not able to look to
see if the dose makes the poison uh as
it were so
you know i i wouldn't i would not be an
absolutist on this topic and say like
look man like
if you're trying to
win usa
usapl nationals and also complete an
ultra marathon and train for both at the
same time you're definitely not going to
have a negative effect on your strength
gains i i don't think that that's a
justifiable take most of these studies
use
pretty moderate levels of endurance
training in them so i i think the
average uh frequency and duration was
like 30 minutes of about 30 minutes of
cardio about three times per week so
like that level of endurance training
when combined with resistance training
if you're doing the endurance training
and resistance training in separate
sessions
doesn't seem to have a negative effect
on strength development
but if you did considerably more
endurance training it probably would um
but at least this meta-analysis doesn't
really give us any clues for where that
threshold buys um
and the other thing i'll note
just uh related to this meta-analysis
is when people talk about concurrent
training
the first study they generally bring up
and for good reason uh is a study by
hixson from 1980. uh this this is kind
of the granddaddy of them all in the
concurrent training literature title is
interference of strength development by
simultaneous by simultaneously training
for strength and endurance so the title
of this study is where the term
interference effect comes from
the study was from 1980 it was the first
study um
rigorously looking at the interference
effect and whether concurrent training
uh had negative effects on strength
development
and so yeah this is the first study that
people tend to cite um
and
it has a pretty
large effect so
um in this meta-analysis the hixson
study the the effect in favor of
resistance training only over endurance
training was about .61 uh and the
subjects in that study were moderately
trained which
again i would probably refer to as
untrained so when you look at the total
batch of effect sizes
from studies on moderately trained or
untrained subjects in this meta-analysis
the pooled effect size for all of those
is about point one uh and the hixson
study i believe had the either the
largest or second largest effect size of
any study that had been done uh and the
effect size for that was about six times
larger than the pooled effect size uh of
the other studies on untrained and
moderately trained subjects so it's
it's very not representative of the body
of literature um which isn't a knock on
it but this relates to something we've
talked about on the podcast before
and that is
when a body of literature is just
developing you shouldn't necessarily
assume that the
average effect seen in the first couple
of studies in the area are is going to
be representative of where kind of the
pooled effect estimate will wind up once
more research is done
and it can go in both directions so the
typical way it goes is that early effect
estimates are quite a bit larger than
the eventual
kind of pooled effect estimate that a
body of literature settles on
uh and and the reason for that is
well there are several reasons for that
but one of the biggest ones
is that most early research in a
particular area is just kind of like
proof of concept research where
if you are
hixson you're an enterprising researcher
in 1980 and you think that doing
concurrent training will lead to smaller
strength gains than just doing
resistance training if that is your
assumption
what you need to do is you need to
publish research showing
that this is an area of research that
warrants further study and so you're
essentially trying you're trying to
design a study that will find a positive
effect to validate the need for further
research and so i i don't have the the
details in front of me right now but if
memory serves the endurance training
protocol in the hixson study
was one of the more challenging
endurance training protocols that has
been done in any concurrent training
study up to this point
so it was basically designed to find an
effect and then once that effect was
found future studies have kind of used
more
uh kind of more chill more
representative i suppose endurance
training protocols and have found
considerably smaller effects
sometimes it can work in the opposite
direction as well so for example if say
a supplement comes on the market and
they find that uh maybe this has a small
positive effect it could it could turn
out to be that like a different form of
the supplement could be more effective
uh it could be that the dose used in the
first studies was too small and so you
could see an increase in the pooled
effect estimate over time but
uh the key point is just that like if
there's only one or two studies in a
body of literature
it very well could be the case that the
effect they're seeing is a real effect
but the magnitude of the effect being
reported
may not necessarily be representative of
where that body of literature will end
up
so that that was just
a little tidbit i pulled out of uh the
concurrent training meta
and then the final thing i want to talk
about is uh muscle damage
um and and eccentric training in
particular but
uh more more just like mitigation of
muscle damage in general
uh so i wrote an article titled does
eccentric training always cause more
muscle damage the title of the article i
was reviewing
was eccentric exercise per se does not
affect muscle damage biomarkers early
and late phase adaptations
uh
by a name i don't feel like trying to
pronounce
um
out of respect
you want to possibly disrespect them by
no i'm gonna i'm gonna roll the dice
margaret ellis maybe
anyway
uh so this study was pretty
straightforward they took a group of
untrained individuals uh split them in
half randomized them into groups and had
them do isokinetic knee extensions once
once per week
for 10 weeks
and all of these training sessions were
just five sets of 15 maximal repetitions
and one group did five sets of 15
maximal concentric reps so you know
basically you set up the dynamometer to
only move at a slow angular velocity and
you just say kick kick kick kick kick
kick as hard as you possibly can for
five sets of 15
concentric only and then the other group
did eccentric only reps so again you set
the dynamometer at a slow angular
velocity and it's going to flex your
knee and what you're trying to do is
resist it with as much force as possible
um
so over the 10 weeks the researchers
monitored
quite a few
indirect markers of muscle damage so
they assessed pain-free range of motion
delayed onset muscle soreness isometric
peak torque at 90 degrees of knee
flexion
concentric peak torque eccentric peak
torque creatine kinase levels
which is a
indirect marker of muscle damage and c
reactive protein levels which is a
marker of inflammation
uh they assessed all of those things for
a couple of days after each training
session throughout the entire 10-week
protocol
and what they found is that for the
first couple of training sessions uh
they found exactly what you would expect
the eccentric training caused way more
muscle damage than the concentric
training for
every marker of muscle damage and
performance they looked at so
pain-free range of motion was decreased
to a greater extent delayed onset muscle
soreness was greater uh isometric torque
decreased to a greater extent concentric
torque decreased to a greater extent
eccentric torque decreased to a greater
extent larger elevations in creatine
kinase levels and larger elevations in c
reactive protein levels so for the first
three weeks of training
every single one of those markers
indicated greater muscle damage for
eccentric training than constant than
concentric training
from weeks four to seven it was kind of
a transitional period where some of
those indirect markers of muscle damage
kind of dropped out of showing a
difference between uh exercise protocols
so
like on week four
most of the markers still suggested more
muscle damage with eccentric training
but now concentric peak torque changes
post training they didn't differ between
groups anymore by week six you're no
longer seeing differences in soreness
isometric peak torque concentric peak
torque and c reactive protein and then
from weeks uh eight to ten you basically
weren't seeing differences between
exercise protocols at all um
there was no indication
that the eccentric only training was
still causing more muscle damage than
the concentric only training
so
i think that this was a pretty powerful
illustration
that when we talk about the repeated
bouts effect and the ability of muscles
to
protect themselves and become more
resilient against muscle damage over
time
a kind of a question there is like to
what extent can those adaptations occur
like what
what can the muscles kind of on the
upper end of things protect themselves
against to mitigate muscle damage
and this study suggests to me that they
can uh
that that functionally there's limitless
capacity and the reason i say that is
like you know the practical question is
can the repeated bout effect occur to
such an extent that normal resistance
training no longer causes really any
significant level of muscle damage
and if they were finding
uh basically no indication that muscle
damage was occurring by
the end of 10 weeks in this study with
that eccentric training protocol
that suggests to me that you can
absolutely get to the point where
virtually no muscle damage is occurring
with just normal training the reason i
say that is this eccentric training
protocol was
it's hard to overstate how much more
brutal it was than anything that anyone
would ever do in the gym for
the purpose of just like normal
resistance training so you hear five
sets of 15 and you think like oh that's
uh that's kind of high volume work i
think i'd be a little sore from that
five sets of 15 is not the same thing as
five sets of 15 maximal eccentric reps
um
i mean like just one set of 15 maximal
eccentric reps would would probably uh
[ __ ] most people
no matter how well trained you are if
you did
like the first week of the eccentric
training protocol here i promise you you
would be wrecked for three or four days
like that's
that's an enormous amount of eccentric
stress so if the subjects could fully
kind of accommodate that after just 10
weeks of training which uh was just 10
sessions of training because they were
only training once per week
uh that suggests that within kind of
practical boundaries uh the repeated
bout effect is is sufficient to
to probably mitigate virtually all
muscle damage that occurs and so um
i i think that this is very relevant
for people who who wonder like hey man
i've been training consistently for a
while i used to get kind of sore after
training i don't really get sore anymore
is that a sign that something is wrong
probably not um
significantly mitigating and and perhaps
going away completely over time that's a
very normal outcome um
and and it's perfectly fine there's no
strong evidence that soreness is
particularly predictive of training
outcomes so
um you know that that is a normal thing
to expect and you shouldn't be concerned
about it uh conversely you may be
wondering like hey if the subjects here
in this study uh we're basically
mitigating all muscle damage after 10
weeks of training why do i still get
sore if i've been training consistently
for a while
and i think probably the main
contributor is just exercise variety or
training variety you know you're
changing rep ranges you're changing
exercise you're maybe changing range of
motion and how you're executing reps etc
um
and repeated bout effect related
adaptations are both general and
specific so
if you are
someone who's reasonably well trained in
a particular style of training and you
do
a workout with a different style of
training
you you have some general protective
adaptations such that
you will probably be less sore following
that training session than a completely
untrained person would be
but uh the adaptations are specific to
some degree so
you know you don't you don't have uh
full muscle damage resistance against
all things that could possibly cause
muscle damage so
uh a key component of this study was
subjects did do the exact same exercise
protocol every time it was five sets of
15 maximal eccentric knee extensions um
at a fixed angular velocity
um
through a fixed range of motion so once
you start changing variables around uh
you are probably still causing some
muscle damage uh due to some degree of
novelty and variety in your training so
you know it's
it's reasonable to expect some degree of
soreness moving forward especially if
training variables are shifting but it's
also very reasonable to expect
uh very very substantial decreases in
muscle soreness perhaps going away
entirely those are both
very very normal uh outcomes of training
and neither of them suggest that
anything
bad is going on so if you've if you've
ever worried about anything related to
soreness am i not getting sore enough am
i getting too sore it's probably fine
everything's fine you don't need to
worry about it
um
and then the last thing i want i kind of
wanted to draw out of this study
is i think that these findings are
relevant to the idea of training to
failure
so um
[Music]
one of the ideas that i think people
have falsely gotten about me
is that i'm against training to failure
that i that i'm an anti-failure crusader
um
and like i'm just i'm not uh so i have
argued multiple times uh and will
continue to do so that you don't need to
train to failure
every set to maximize the per set
hypertrophy outcomes
if you're
acquainted with the quote unquote
effective reps model of hypertrophy i've
argued against that i i don't think that
the evidence substantiates it and i
think that there's a pretty reasonable
amount of evidence against it
um
but
the the statement of i don't think you
need to go to failure all the time to
maximize hypertrophy is not the same as
i am against training to failure and in
fact
i do most of my training to failure um
not for squat bench deadlift but for
basically everything else
largely because i think it idiot proofs
training
like you know i don't want to have to
think about my level of effort when i'm
exercising
um
you know i i i think if i'm
trying to think like okay what is the
perfect sub-maximal amount of effort to
exert to minimize the fatigue
accumulated in this set but maximize the
hypertrophic adaptation in this set i
don't know some people maybe are into
that i'm [ __ ] not uh
like i'm gonna think about it a little
bit for my core lifts for everything
else i just want to turn my brain off
and lift stuff like i like lifting stuff
and making myself tired that's
those are some of the things i love
about training um
so i just don't want to have to think
about it too too hard i think that
training to failure largely idiot proofs
your training and when i'm training i am
an idiot
um now is that is that failure failure
or is it like
volitional failure without
digging into like my absolute top gear
that's like failure failure okay um
it depends on the lift uh
like
i don't like being pinned by squats
um
interesting yeah it's it's not my
favorite thing but for
i don't know like dumbbell press i'm
just going to press until like i can't
actually get the weights up anymore and
then i say oh well i guess i'm done no
more reps yeah uh
tricep extensions same thing just keep
going once i can't lock it out you know
i'm just going to bring the bar to my
chest close grip press it up so yeah i
mean like failure failure
um
so yeah
and one of the
because i just want to say i went back
into your lifting videos and when you
claim to go to failure i actually found
that you had seven reps left in the tent
we're not we're not doing this
[Laughter]
oh man um
[Music]
yeah
so
uh
so people who are like actually
anti-failure training
the the biggest argument they'll bring
up is that there's there's plenty of
research it's not even worth citing
individual studies there is a robust and
flourishing body of evidence
showing
that when you train to failure it causes
larger decrements in performance pre to
post training and requires longer to
recover from an exercise session than
doing kind of uh
non-failure training that's equated for
reps or total volume load and so you
know people will argue that like the
cost benefit calcul calculus doesn't
make sense here if you can get just as
much muscle growth not training to
failure
but when you train to failure
you're causing more fatigue you're
taking longer to recover and you're not
really getting anything in return
that constitutes a strong reason to not
go to failure in training and to
advocate against really ever training to
failure um
but i don't go that far and and some of
the findings from this study and you
know prior to the study being published
just my own experience constituted
reasons why i don't necessarily buy that
argument um
so you know if people can acclimate to
5 sets of 15 of maximal eccentric reps
i think people can [ __ ] acclimate to
training to failure um
such that like
if you do
if you do a study in in you
this kind of drifts off your point you
made about muscle protein synthesis
research if you put people through
unaccustomed exercise they're not used
to it's causing a lot of muscle damage
maybe mps isn't necessarily
representative i think the same thing
applies to
research looking at how different
training variables impact muscle damage
and fatigue and recovery from training
where if you're putting someone through
an unaccustomed exercise protocol
their
post exercise response to that may not
necessarily be representative of how
their post exercise response would look
if they trained in that manner for a
matter of weeks or months and and that's
been my experience with uh with failure
training like if i've been doing a
highly specific block of power lifting
stuff with really no accessory work um
and not doing basically any training to
failure then like you know when i when i
toss in some skull crushers and just
like really push myself to the limits my
triceps are gonna be [ __ ] for three or
four days after that but then if i do it
for like
three weeks four weeks or something like
that
my triceps don't get sore anymore and
they don't they don't really seem to be
any more fatigued post-training than
they would be if i didn't go to failure
so i i think that this study
indirectly supports that observation
that you know most things that might
cause more muscle damage than other
things and in this case i'm talking
about training to failure i think if you
do those things whatever they are
for
not even that extended of a period of
time but like you know four five six
seven eight workouts um
i think eventually your body just adapts
to it you acclimate it no longer causes
that much additional muscle damage or
fatigue and it's fine so
uh i and i could just be kind of playing
into my own confirmation biases here
because
brother you're never going to get me to
to estimate reps in reserve on a set of
rear delt flies i'm never going to do it
like that's always going to failure uh
and you know if i'm wrong if that's
sub-optimal i don't [ __ ] care because
i i am never going to tell you my rpe
for a set of of dealt raises it's always
ten it's only ever going to be ten i'm
not going to stop that shy of failure
and you can't make me and that's the
point that's what mass is all about it's
a it's about finding things
that
reinforce my biases
and then if someone disagrees with me i
threaten to fight them yeah you can
you can take the dumbbells
out of my completely fatigued rpe 10
hands uh if you try to make me stop
earlier you're gonna you're gonna have a
dumbbell hurtling at your head from
across the gym
and i will have no remorse
um
and that's an evidence-based perspective
anyway 21 a month it's the lowest prices
of the year uh
sign up now
yeah so uh just to confirm your point
you know you talked about
uh
the repeated bowed effect being you know
specific to the type of training
to an extent
uh
dude this is insane so bicep training
bicep curls are a staple in my training
they're they just are
uh my 12 mile run the other day dude my
biceps were sore
because uh just from holding your arms
in a running position dude it takes a
long time to run 12 miles if you're me
and yeah a
multiple hour isometric or you know hour
and a half isometric or however long it
took me
not what i was training for not at all
and i was pretty stunned at how sore my
biceps were but uh
i assume i'll adapt to that as well dude
you know what you know what always gets
me what
so when i haven't played basketball for
a while uh
and i go out and get a pretty good run
in um
one of the things that gets the most
sore for me is my neck
because like i i have kind of a big neck
i don't really do any neck training um
i should i i i don't really like neck
training but i want to have a huge neck
anyway
first world problems but anyway so i
don't really do any neck training uh and
when i go out and play basketball just
from like changing directions like
jumping landing kind of hard like
there's
like isometric forces trying to pull my
head out of
alignment that you know i'm i'm
resisting in real time
and uh so dude yeah like
my neck extensors always get so sore if
i play basketball when i haven't in a
while um
i think that's kind of conceptually
similar just like soreness and a muscle
that you that you wouldn't expect yeah
all right so uh it seems like we covered
a lot of stuff there but uh we are
really just scratching the surface when
it comes to mass uh if you
subscribe to mass you do get access to
the entire archive and we are now
entering our sixth year of content uh
this upcoming january
uh so we're finishing up currently
volume five moving on to volume six
each issue it comes out every single
month has nine to ten pieces of content
i think we're over the 400 mark in terms
of the total number of pieces of content
uh last time i looked but i think it's
like 550.
so okay over 400 confirmed uh but anyway
yeah there's so much information in
there so many pieces of content uh and
like i said if you do wish to subscribe
uh the sale goes through november 29th
uh so before we wrap up the episode i do
want to answer a couple very quick q a
questions and then we'll wrap up
so the first one is from marcus the
question is do i have any concerns about
upper limits for soy intake
do i have any issues with getting you
know a pretty substantial amount of your
your protein coming from soy and the
question asks you know up to like 1.6 or
2.2 grams per kilogram all coming from
soy protein
usually when people ask this question
they have
two concerns that are somewhat related
the first concern
is about the potentially estrogenic side
effects uh related to soy isoflavones
uh and then people wonder you know is
there potentially going to be
some kind of like feminizing impact from
uh from this estrogenic stuff and then
secondarily
and then the second uh opposite concern
is of course will it make my dick too
hard correct yeah the secondary concern
related to that is will it impact
hypertrophy to some extent yeah that
never mind sorry uh so anyway uh it's a
question that comes up a lot and what's
really interesting my whole body too
turgid
correct
the thing that is interesting about this
is that i see a lot of answers that are
extremely definitive one way or the
other and i kind of
uh
aim for the middle ground a little bit
so here's what i can say and i'll post
some links in the description of today's
show
a great study by our friend cody han
who's a stronger by science coach
he did a ton of really great work when
he was working on his phd
out at auburn their lab does some really
fascinating stuff but
they're looking at different types of
protein supplementation and in this case
uh i think the the title kind of gives
it away the paper's called soy protein
supplementation is not androgenic or
estrogenic in aged men when combined
with resistance exercise training so
even at doses up to about 80 grams per
day of soy protein
they did not observe any estrogenic
effects
that would be physiologically meaningful
there's also a meta-analysis of 15
randomized controlled trials that i'm
aware of indicating that
soy protein supplementation had no
significant effect on total testosterone
free testosterone
or sex hormone blind binding globulin
and within those rcts uh the the the soy
protein content was typically between 10
and 70 grams of soy protein
and the isoflavone content which is what
people are largely focused on
was between like 60 to 240 milligrams
so based on that a lot of people say
there's absolutely no connection there
under no circumstance could there be a a
concern or or uh should it be a
consideration whatsoever i'm not quite
prepared to go that far just because
like we've talked about this in various
places but i tend to be more of an
empiricist
you know i i i like empirical arguments
more than trying to rationalize my way
to an argument so when i can lean on
empirical data i much prefer to i feel
more comfortable with it
um
so i feel very extremely comfortable
that with doses up to like 80 grams a
day of soy protein i really don't have
concerns especially if the isoflavone
content of that soy protein product is
staying within that range i mentioned
uh there are a couple case studies that
have been published case studies you
take them with a grain of salt but uh
you know people who are consuming up to
like
360 milligrams of soy isoflavones per
day for like six to twelve months at a
time where uh they have noted some
adverse effects uh that that
could be considered a bit estrogenic in
nature uh or kind of linked to these
estrogenic concerns so um
there are case studies out there uh and
you can put whatever stock you want into
those but uh
up to like 80 grams a day i feel
extremely confident
and then when it comes to the
hypertrophy stuff
i mentioned that that study previously
looking at hypertrophy over the course
of a uh 12-week resistance training
program um
the the
vegan group who was supplementing with
soy protein
had extremely similar
uh training adaptations in terms of
hypertrophy so leg lean mass whole
muscle cross-sectional area muscle fiber
cross-sectional area strength
all those training adaptations were
quite similar and they were getting 0.8
grams per kilogram per day
purely from soy protein um it did just
based on their weights i think it ended
up being like 57 or 58 grams a day so
just from an empirical perspective i
feel extremely comfortable you know that
up to 80 grams a day or you know up to
like half of your protein for the day
coming purely from soy uh simply doesn't
seem to be an issue for any of
any concerns within this kind of
umbrella of topics uh when you start
doubling those numbers i simply don't
know i don't know if you have a strong
opinion on that but
um
i like to be
more
guided by empirical evidence when
possible and this just kind of seems to
be
where it ends in controlled trials is
with doses up around 80 grams a day
here's what i have a strong opinion
about so
a couple of times friends have come over
and i've been making little treats okay
uh
you know the story you were here
um so
making some little treats
like uh like
fried chicken either chicken wings or
like little uh
like popcorn chicken or whatever and
then for vegetarian and vegan friends
some uh
similarly either battered or breaded and
fried and then sauced soy puffs yes and
i gotta say
this is coming from a completely
inveterate omnivore that
loves meat i like it it's good the
[ __ ] fried soy puffs are are better
than every other
meat option that has been available
every time that i've
uh like prepared and fried and sauced
the same thing like yeah the the soy
puffs beat out chicken
they beat out like i made some just
insane fried meatballs but then also
made some fried soy puffs the [ __ ]
soy puffs were better i gotta say man
culinarily they're
they're incredible because they're just
like
they're puffs there's a lot of air in
them they can soak up any flavor uh they
have an excellent texture and mouth feel
so um
yeah
my only strong opinion about soy is that
if you're
if you're an omnivore and you're a
foodie and
you have some vegetarian or vegan
friends coming over and you're like ah
like i don't know
what sort of of meat substitute or meat
alternative to have if you were going to
make a little a little fried treat uh
just just using whatever recipe you were
going to use otherwise but subbing in
whatever meat option you're going to
have for soy puffs swear to god best
decision you'll ever make and you will
probably also like the soy puffs better
than than the meat option they're
they're so good they're incredible you
know another time that happened uh there
have been some cases where you've made a
a mushroom based version of something uh
as opposed to a meat based version there
have been instances where the mushroom
version is better
mushrooms are also very good mushrooms
are very good so i think a lot of people
when they consider
uh you know incorporating more
vegetarian meals they're like well i
have officially departed from flavor
town and i can never go back
and that's really not the case there's
some really nice options but
uh just to kind of put a little anecdote
on top of this uh
you know i still consume whey protein
for i believe reasons we've discussed on
the podcast like i think uh from a
ethical and environmental standard uh
viewpoint it kind of fits within my
uh
i'm comfortable with it from from those
perspectives just because
a lot of the whey that goes into whey
protein powder seems to be
essentially just a byproduct of
conventional dairy food production that
they're they're just gonna kind of get
rid of either way
so i don't lose a lot of sleep over
having a lot of protein coming from whey
protein supplements but i do eat a lot
of soy protein coming from things like
soy crumbles that's my main source of
soy protein that i get often
have i ever
once counted how many grams i'm getting
from soy absolutely not
so i i try to separate out like from a
purely empirical point of view there are
case reports trending in that direction
with extremely high intakes and very
well controlled trials showing no such
effect up to about 80 grams a day would
i start getting nervous if i had 100
grams a day coming from soy products
i definitely wouldn't uh i'm pretty
comfortable that unless you have a truly
anomalous intake of soy uh you're
probably not gonna run into these types
of concerns that that would be my my
estimation but to make that estimation
you do have to deviate from the
empirical evidence a little bit
now one other thing i i wanted to
mention here or another uh question i
wanted to answer before we wrap up
this question is from jake uh
the question is it's curious to hear
about
evidence regarding different types of
liquid carb sources intra workout so
sometimes this individual jake trains
for over two hours in brazilian jiu
jitsu has been trying a poly
polysaccharide product made from potato
rice and corn
and this is something that really got
big in the fitness world these kind of
designer carbohydrates and highly
branched cyclic dextrin exactly you'd
hear about these products high molecular
weight carbohydrate you'd hear about
molecular weight that was always a big
selling point and they talk about the
exact branched structure of the the
uh the starch polymer of a particular
product
um i gotta be honest so i i did uh
publish one study on uh kind of like
designer carbohydrate back in grad
school at that time i had looked into
the literature and
i had never seen anything that was
particularly uh spectacular from some of
these designer carbohydrate products i'd
never seen anything where i was like wow
that is a huge deal and makes a big
difference
i haven't revisited that literature in
detail in a while but i honestly don't
think you can do much better than a very
simple
six to eight percent carbohydrate
solution uh the total amount of
carbohydrate you would ingest ultimately
depends on the volume and the intensity
of the work that you're doing and of
course by extension the duration as well
so i mean you know
30 grams an hour maybe up to 60 grams an
hour unless you're doing really
prolonged really intense stuff that's
usually plenty to get you through uh and
when it comes to like i said a six to
eight percent carbohydrate solution as a
beverage
i think you know
if you're only having like 30 grams per
hour
the exact source of carbohydrate doesn't
really seem to matter that much
but if you're the more that you ramp up
your intake in grams per hour the more
you have to think about transporters in
the gut and so glucose and fructose are
transported a little bit differently so
when you start really pushing the carbon
take intra workout you have to consider
what's going to be
very efficiently taken up into systemic
circulation you also have to consider
what's going to be
easier on your gut in terms of reducing
gi distress so that that's why i do like
to have a liquid uh source of carbs in
order to get around some of those
considerations a really simple way to do
it is to have a ratio of approximately
two to one when you're considering your
carb source and thinking
in the digestion process what simple
sugar is this going to end up being
before it's absorbed usually a a ratio
of two parts glucose to one part
fructose is a good place to start
um
and so
what i mention here six to eight percent
carbohydrate approximately two to one
ratio of glucose to fructose you're
gonna find similar stuff
in pretty
pretty much any commercial sports
beverage that isn't like the special
zero or low carb version so if you were
to just get like a regular
gatorade or powerade or whatever it is
big these days it's probably going to be
pretty close to fitting these criteria
and this is pretty much what the
evidence would push you towards so for
me personally if i was i know it doesn't
sound very interesting or sophisticated
or nuanced but like if i was gonna do
some stuff that needed some
intra-workout carb
i'd probably grab a gatorade uh and
i think there's probably a reason why
like in high level sport that is
a very common way to go with it
have you looked into any of the research
uh suggesting that if you consume highly
branched cyclic dextrin during your
workout
uh the increased gains you're going to
experience will be quote nothing less
than shocking
no where was that published uh
t nation okay on on the plasma sales
page
so
uh whenever i think about this stuff i
always think about the t nation uh
sales campaign when they launched plasma
their reactive pump supplement
so uh let's just read from from these
research findings that they that they
published on their sales page
the plasma formula also contains highly
branched cyclic dextrin which is a
specialized carbohydrate that
significantly increases metabolic rate
and performance levels research shows
that highly branched cyclic dextrin
benefits athletes in these powerful ways
increases vo2 max in time to exhaustion
and elite swimmers makes intense
exercise actually feel easier decreases
stress hormone levels following
exhaustive exercise provides rapid
hydration and nutrient loading without
increasing gastric emptying time and
increases endurance to fatigue by 27
percent over glucose supplementation and
doesn't spike insulin in comparison
taking timed plasma doses before during
and after training loads the muscles
with key anabolic nutrients aka glucose
for maximum i say aka glucose no that's
okay i'm ad-libbing i'm i'm riffing yeah
uh
for maximizing performance and enhanced
recovery the term for this the turn so
here here comes some specialized
some specialized jargon the term for
this muscle engorging effect is called
the quote reactive pump
the reactive pump makes muscle hyper
responsive to nutrient uptake and hyper
responsive to growth signaling it also
provides you with unbreakable
performance in the gym and competition
by uniquely pre-loading and pumping key
nutrients into muscle plasma doses
enable you to perform at
and beyond your limits there are no
limits you can exceed them now uh while
recovering so fast you'll be excited to
go back to the gym not only that the
increased gains you're going to
experience from plasma pulsing will be
nothing less than shocking so anyway um
i mean i think i think they published
this research
back in uh like [ __ ] 2011 or
something it was a blind spot you're
you might be you might be a little bit
behind the the cutting edge empirical
findings here
fair enough uh we will teach it as a
controversy then dude i
loved
i i think we've talked about this before
one of my soft spots is i love
supplement marketing i think it's i
think it's so [ __ ] funny and that
that area or that era of t nation was
the best yeah because like
first they come out with anaconda
delivering the anabolic load i don't
need to spell out the subtext there but
it was basically just like what if we
put together every supplement we sell
into a protocol where like your
supplement
your supplement stack per workout is
gonna run you about eight bucks or
whatever and it's like well okay that's
shameless shameless cash grab very funny
marketing what you got next what they
had next was indigo 3g which is a
basically a blueberry extract that they
were treating as if it was like a state
secret where like the early buyers they
uh
sent them a single bottle and like a
special kevlar case
um
so that that was a very funny roll out
for something that was just like an
anthocyanin extract uh and then the the
end of this golden era of biotest
marketing was plasma which is literally
just like a starch supplement that
they're just and and most of the
marketing leading up to it was just like
they they take prominent individuals in
the fitness community and somehow get
them to say
man i've been training hard and
i've been growing a lot of muscle more
than i expected and somehow
i'm getting too lean i can't stop myself
getting leaner i'm consuming effectively
sugar throughout my entire workout and
somehow i just can't stop getting
shredded yeah
god that was
that was the best they've really they've
really fallen off i don't know how the
business is doing but
uh they have not made as audacious of
supplement claims recently and honestly
i miss it i yeah my i have a biotest new
supplement launch
sized hole in my heart yeah that can
only be filled by a new completely
audacious biotest supplement their next
one was brain candy which
was basically just like a
like basically like a five hour energy
with some feeling in it and like i'm
sure it was fine but like
it wasn't as funny there were no
anabolic loads being delivered yeah um
the the marketing wasn't as over the top
so
uh tc if you're listening to this
hit us with some more of the crazy [ __ ]
double down i need the crazy [ __ ] i need
i need the anabolic load 2.0 yeah um
anyway so i will say i missed the days
when because all that stuff was hitting
when we were like young
and i i remember getting ripped off uh
from all the supplement claims from
various companies but at least it was at
least i had hope in my heart you know i
would buy like
i would literally literally switch from
one pre-workout to another pre-workout
that had a virtually identical set of
ingredients and i'd be like maybe this
is going to be my secret weapon you know
like maybe this is what puts me over the
over the hump here
uh i i very much do miss that type of
optimism
uh and of course the entertainment value
is exceptional
uh okay so i think that does it for this
episode but to play us out i had a
a tip i wanted to share with people i'm
curious to see what you do for this but
i've been searching far and wide for the
perfect
stuff to listen to while i'm working so
when i'm like writing or reading it just
doing general desk work stuff
and i used to try to do uh
regular music with lyrics can't do it
too distracting trying to do podcasts
once again too distracting can't really
tune it out effectively uh even a lot of
music without words i i find to be too
distracting you know what i mean there's
you got the changes in tempo and volume
you've got the the crescendos and the
staccatos and stuff and i'm too tapped
into it
but
i was on spotify the other day and i
found a jazz playlist that is
specifically framed
as being oriented for the mornings
this is not
afternoon jazz this is certainly not
evening time jazz this is morning jazz
and it has been
the most
valuable thing i've ever discovered like
when i'm working it there is nothing
better than it so if you are like me and
you've been searching for the perfect
thing to kind of tune out while you're
working
jazz will do but it's got to be that
morning jazz uh but what do you listen
to when you're trying to do that type of
work i listen to synthwave synthwave i
assume there's no lyrics at all right
uh for the most part no okay i mean
there is some synth wave with lyrics but
i i get the no lyric stuff
okay you'd give that an enthusiastic
recommendation i assume i would if you'd
like to stick your toes in that water
there is a
uh
i don't know if it's a group or an
individual i haven't looked into it too
closely uh but uh the the band on
spotify is home h-o-m-e
um
i i discovered them because there is a
uh speed running channel on youtube i
like called summoning salt
and the uh outro music for for all of
his videos is a song called we're
finally landing by home
and uh i was listening to it one time i
was like dude this would be sick to work
to so i started with home and just
looked at similar artists on spotify put
together a playlist i call focus songs
and uh yeah helps me focus it's good
stuff
all right good stuff uh so that does it
for this episode uh as always thank you
for joining us uh if you happen to
celebrate thanksgiving we hope you
enjoyed it we hope you have safe travels
if you're traveling take care and we'll
be back soon
with another episode